>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Joel Achenback: I have-- this
is actually a real treat for me
to be able to introduce Janna Levin
who's written just a beautiful book,
fascinating book called
"Black Hole Blues
and Other Songs from Outer Space".
Janna Levin is a Professor
of Physics
and Astronomy Barnard College of
Columbia University, she has her PhD
in Physics from MIT, she has
written a couple other books
"How the Universe Got Its Spots",
and she wrote a book called,
"A Madman Dreams of
Turing Machines".
This book, I know probably
many of you in this room heard
about the whole LIGO
experiment earlier this year the
gravitational waves.
How here knows about that?
Good. OK, so we've got some
nerds here, some geeks.
So, a hundred years
ago Einstein predicted
that the universe would resonate
with these gravitational waves
as space itself kind of rippled
from the collision of
super dense objects.
And for a hundred years people try
to figure out how do we detect this?
It's an amazing story.
Now, if Einstein were here today
he probably would say, you know,
I was right, you know,
he didn't need
to check it, I mean, I got this.
You know what I mean?
I got it, really, I'm sure, right?
But experimentalist wanted
to check it out and--
so back in earlier this year
there was this big announcement
down at the National Press Club
where they had detected
these gravitational waves
with this experiment called LIGO
which is actually two enormous
experimental detectors,
one in Louisiana and one in
Washington State that were set
up with incredible precision to
measure the very tiniest change
in space itself as a gravitational
wave pass through the earth.
And they've been working on
this for 40 years and as--
I'm a reporter for the Post, I'm a
science reporter so I went there,
we wrote about it,
it was a big deal.
And there were some
legendary physicists there,
Ray Wise was there,
Kip Thorne was there
and we threw it at our stories.
Well now, Janna Levin comes along
and gives us the real
story, the back story.
And it's beautifully written.
It's told me all kinds of stuff I
wish I had known earlier this year
when I covered it for the newspaper.
I'm, you know, I told
Janna I'm very resentful
when a scientist writes so well.
I mean, why am I-- why do I
exist if-- you know, I mean, we--
if you're a journalist write
about science you count
on scientist being utterly
incomprehensible, right?
You know, and then you
translate it, you know,
it's like what she means
to say is, you know?
But this book is so well
written and-- so please welcome,
give a warm welcome
to Dr. Janna Levin.
[ Applause ]
>> Janna Levin: I wasn't going
to stand behind the podium
because I'm so little.
Hold on I'm going to try
to do this, with the mike.
Well that was basically
my entire talk,
so what do you guys
want to talk about now?
Thank you so much for coming out.
I'm really honored
everyone came out.
I'm here at Book Festivals
as a fan as much as an author
so it's just an absolute bonus to
see everyone out here for this talk.
I know some of you raised
your hands when asked
if you had heard of
the LIGO experiment.
So on February 11th of this
year an obscure experiment
that almost nobody had ever heard
of announced what has been touted
as the scientific discovery
of the century.
It was an early morning
press conference
and people were listening all
over the world and as soon
as the press conference started the
New York Times, I was sitting next
to Dennis Overbye from the New
York Times pressed, you know,
submit on his article and all
of these articles went straight
to the front page of all the
papers it was for 24 hours it was
like the whole world stood
together and stopped and listening.
I was on Al Jazeera TV that night
and I'm looking down the barrel
of this sort of-- I'm in a tiny
box talking to somebody in Qatar,
I don't know where and, you
know, and there's this moment
where they're looking at
me and I'm looking at them.
And they're saying, they're about
to ask me what does this mean
for humanity and then they're
like, I'm sorry to interrupt you
but we have to turn
to the war in Syria.
So, that was like, a second where
everyone paused for something other
than or kind of earthly concerns.
And yet after about
10 minutes I felt
like people weren't sure what
exactly it was all about, right?
How many people after they heard
the announcement felt an hour later
that they didn't really understand
what the hell it was all about?
Oh come on there's
more of you than that.
I don't believe that for a second.
It's a very difficult result.
It's something we've never done
before in the history of humanity.
When LIGO, this experiment,
which again no one had ever heard
of came online and
made the discovery.
What you don't know or maybe some
of you know but I'm assuming many
down is that was a 50 year arguist
[phonetic] claiming of a kind
of scientific Mount Everest
that people gave their
careers over to this campaign.
It cost nearly a billion dollars.
It consisted of two absolutely
colossal machines, one in Louisiana
and one in Washington State,
each one spanning 4 kilometers.
And they had failed in their
initial generation, I mean,
failed is maybe too strong.
The initial generation machine was
built in 2000 and heard nothing.
What LIGO did was not take
a picture of this guide.
These are not telescopes,
these are recording devices.
It recorded literally the
shape of space-time ringing
from two black holes, 1.3
billion years ago colliding.
And what I'd like to do more or
less for the rest of my half hour
or so is pick a part what
discovery meant and what happened
and why it's so significant.
So let's see if our
technology is working.
I'm going to play for
you the recording.
And this is, you know, we're jut
going to listen to it for a second
and then we're going to spend
the rest of the time trying
to understand how this is possible.
So LIGO Hanford, the
instrument-- Oh, that's loud.
And that's LIGO Livingston
in Louisiana.
And, so what the hell is that about?
I mean, what does that even mean?
What does that even mean?
How many of you are like sci-fi
fans who know that there's no
such thing as sound in empty space?
You know if you watch a sci-fi
movie and you see somebody screaming
in the vacuum you're going
to be totally annoyed, right?
There's no sound in empty space.
How can this possibly be sound?
And I'm going to argue to you
that this was literally something we
could hear but it's incredibly quiet
by the time it gets to the earth.
So let's do a little picking a part
of what this discovery
was actually about.
This is a view of our
Milky Way galaxy taken
from the European Southern
Observatory in Chile.
It's this dry barren bit of
brittle earth and that's perfect
for astronomical viewing.
The skies are dry it
means there's not a lot
of interference you
can just look out.
This is taken just
with a digital camera.
If you can imagine holding
your eyes open long enough,
you could see this.
The Milky Way is this
spectacular rift on the sky.
And if you think about where
we really are in the galaxy,
we live in the galactic suburbs.
New Yorkers are always
terribly offended by that fact.
They really resent that, but we do.
We live safely outside the center of
the galaxy in the galactic suburbs
and this is the view from
our sky, the Milky Way.
The reason it looks like it does
is because we live inside it.
OK, we can't look at
it from the outside.
There is our star it's a pretty
average star, it's a yellow star.
And as we all know
we're the third rock
from the sun there's a
hundred billion stars
in the Milky Way galaxy
and there's probably tens
at least billions of
planets like ours.
But, you know, we've never gone
anywhere and we've been to the moon.
So this thing about
putting a flag in the moon,
that's real that's not
a conspiracy theory.
We have been to the moon.
But our biggest aspiration
right now is just to go to Mars,
it's our galactic, you know,
it's our solar neighborhood.
We've barely gone to anywhere.
And so if you think
of being so confined
to this tiny region outside our
rocky planet the galaxy itself,
the center of the galaxy
is 26,000 light years away.
The whole galaxy is a hundred
thousand or so light years across
and we've only gone
to the moon, you know,
which is seconds away
in terms of light speed.
And so here we are confined to
this little solar neighborhood
and almost everything we know
about the universe is
brought to us by light.
We wait patiently,
we build telescopes
and we take pictures of the sky.
This is not a cartoon.
This is an actual map of all the
galaxies we've ever discovered
in the universe, the
observable universe.
There are as many galaxies
in the sky
as there are stars
in our own milky way.
So there are hundreds of billion
of galaxies, everything you see
in this map is an entire galaxy.
And we collect this sort of map of
the universe by taking pictures.
You know, ever since Galileo
pointed a telescope at the sky,
we've made this kind
of silent movie, right,
of these collected snapshots
that date back 14 billion years
and stretched over 90
billion light years across.
It's really an incredibly
extraordinary image,
yet all of that stuff, all of it
in the entire observable universe,
everything we have ever seen
including everything we see
on this earth, everything
on this room,
everything out in the farthest
reaches of space make up less
than 5% of what exist
in the universe.
More than 95% of the
universe is in dark stuff,
stuff that can't be seen,
dark matter or dark energy
and it will never come
to us through light.
And that's really quite a
stunning realization to understand
that as vast and spectacular
the universe looks to us
in pictures it's a very modest
fraction of what's out there.
My favorite terrain of the entire
cosmos is the dark, darkness,
you know, the vast
emptiness of space-time,
the darkest parts of the universe.
This is a portrait of a black hole.
I'm proud to say I did that myself.
A black hole, you know,
black holes are out there.
We see them indirectly because
they destroy their neighboring
environment but there's many, many
black holes that we don't see.
There's probably a billion
black holes in our own galaxy
and we only see a handful.
The center of our galaxy has a
black hole 4 million times the mass
of the sun and we only know
it's there because of the orbits
of the stars and the inner system.
It's completely dark.
This is what a black hole would look
like if we could see it up close,
there's some evil civilization
figured out how
to collapse a sun to a black hole.
It would collapse down
to 6 kilometers across.
Isn't that spectacular, the entire
mass of the sun in 6 kilometers.
I know all my references
are New York based
but you're going to
have to forgive me.
That would fit in Manhattan.
You could fit that
black hole in Manhattan
but then it would destroy the earth
so that wouldn't be a good idea
but this is also an illustration
that black holes have this kind
of horrible reputation as
engines of terrible destruction
but actually you'd be perfectly safe
in orbit around a black hole sun.
Isn't that like a song?
Is that Soundgarden?
You'd be perfectly safe in your
orbit around a black hole sun.
There's nothing wrong with your
orbit it's exactly the same.
In fact, as the suns pull
on gravitational pull.
The only problem is it would be
apocalyptically cold and dark
and that would be really
unfortunate but.
In this computer model which
was made by Andrew Hamilton
from Colorado, the little earth
model was kind of self-illuminated.
But that black hole
is only 6 kilometers
across so that's a tiny
little pseudo earth satellite.
Oh, sorry.
Did I do something bad?
I did something bad.
I'm back. Thanks.
But the important thing
to notice about this is
that what the black hole really
does even though it's dark
and we can't see it is it creates
curvatures in space-time itself
and that means that even light bends
when it travels around a black hole.
So notice that while this earth
passes behind this black hole sun
you can still see it.
You can still see it because the
light gets lands back at you.
We've never seen anything
like this in reality.
We can't see black holes like this.
There is an experiment to try
to measure the dark shadow
of a black hole in the
center of our galaxy.
It's 4 million times the mass
the sun but it fits in a handful
of sun widths which is
crazy, crazy density of mass
but it's 26,000 light years
away and there's an experiment
that uses essentially all of
the telescopes on the earth
to try to resolve the shadow.
It's equivalent to trying to
resolve a quarter on the moon.
And I really believe this will be
successful in the next year or so.
I think you're going to be
seeing the first actual pictures
of a black hole that we've
every seen in the history
of humanity in the next year or so.
If there was a black hole
between us and the Milky Way,
what we just saw this great rift
of the Milky Way and we were to try
to fall into it you're
an astronaut orbiting
around it this is what
you might see.
The spectacular thing about black
holes is that there's nothing there.
And people think black holes are
these dense crushes of matter
but there's actually
nothing there at all.
If you fall across the shadow
of a black hole it's empty.
It's empty space-time.
Maybe you guys can ask me questions
about that later if you want.
But also, the other myth
about the black hole is
that they're completely dark.
Black holes are dark from the
outside but not on the inside.
If you were to fall into a
black hole you'd have a full,
I don't know, microsecond
of bright light falling
in behind you from
the entire galaxy.
It would be like you saw the
evolution and the history
of the entire galaxy
falling in behind you
and you could get this
bright flash of light.
These are again computer
models and not cartoons.
So as you fall towards the center
of the black hole, all that light
from the galaxy that falls
behind you becomes concentrated
into this bright flash of light.
I used to jokingly call it a
near-death experience, you know,
when you see the light at the
end of the tunnel only it's
like a total death experience
because you get crushed to death
in the center of the black hole.
We don't really know what
happens in the center.
That's still a mystery because
all the material that fall
into a black hole get blown
out into another universe,
is there another big bag
inside the black hole.
Is the black hole much bigger on the
inside than it is on the outside?
Is it as big as a universe
on the inside?
These are thing we don't
actually know the answer to
but are all conceivable
possibilities.
You know, Dr. Who TARDIS, you walk
inside and it's huge on the inside,
that's like the black hole.
It's 6 kilometers across
on the outside
but it's an entire
universe on the inside.
It's not an experiment I
recommend anyone tries.
OK, so here we are coming up to
this great event that happened.
When Einstein theorized
about all of these things,
the curvature of space-time
and his most famous accomplishment
the general theory of relativity,
it's like 1915 he finally writes
down the correct mathematical
expression
for his theory of general
relativity.
And the first thing he
turns to is the question
of what he calls gravitational
waves.
He says if an object can curve
space and time around it then
when the object moves surely
those curves have to move with it.
And he imagined they
would create waves,
waves literally in
the shave of space.
If you were floating nearby a black
hole and it moved, you would have
to sort of bob on the wave
communicating to you just
like fish swirling in a pound
that this object had moved.
And he labored over this for years.
This was 1915, 1916.
In 1930s when he was asked, are
these gravitational waves real?
Einstein said, I don't know,
you know, I really don't know.
He would write a paper
saying they do not exist.
It would be accepted
for publication.
Between acceptance and
publication he would sneak
in a completely different paper that
said that they do exist, you know.
And then people say,
Einstein you've got
to be very careful your famous name
is going to be on these papers.
And he would say, my
name is on a lot
of wrong papers just
don't worry about it.
It's not his concern.
But this debate went
on into the '70s.
But I'm going to show you very
sophisticated current model
of what happens as two
black holes collide,
this is again a computer model.
And what it's really showing you is
those natural curves and space-time
around the objects and as
they orbit it makes a wave
and then they collide and
form a new black hole.
That's the current thinking and
that flattens out space-time
and eventually that
black hole goes quiet.
Now, what does this
have to do with sound?
Oops, sorry.
That was abrupt.
What does this have
to do with sound?
The argument is if you were
floating nearby those black holes,
you would literally hear them
even in the absence of air,
even in vacuum because the
space-time changing would squeeze
and stretch you as it passed.
And because your eardrum is
built to resonate and response
to being squeezed and stretched,
you would literally
technically hear the waves even
in the absence of air.
It happens that the two black holes
that collided that were detected
in September ring in the
human auditory range.
It's just a ridiculous
coincidence that it's literally
in the human auditory range.
This is a model from my group,
where we show in yellow the orbit
of one black hole, in
red the orbit of another,
this is just a theoretical
prediction, and simultaneously play
for you what you would hear
if you were floating
dangerously close to those.
It might be a little loud
because it's going to get louder.
Notice you can hear
details of the orbits.
It's like mallets on
a drum banging a drum.
You can reconstruct the size
and the motion of the mallets
by listening to the sound.
Black hole orbits can
be very complicated.
Notice how it gets quiet, and
loud, then it get quiet again.
These are things that allow us to
reconstruct the size and motion
of the mallets by listening.
That little chirp at the end is
really goofy, everyone laughs
at that because everyone
thinks black holes are going
to sound way more butch
that they actually do.
They sort of have this like sort
of little feminine
chirp at the end there.
But that chirp is an
extremely characteristic
of black hole collisions,
extremely characteristic.
What's happening is the black
holes begin to orbit so quickly
in the final fraction of a second
they're orbiting near the speed
of light that the frequency at which
they're banging space and time,
the drum, goes up and it
creates this sort of scooping
up chirp right before it goes quiet.
And it goes quiet because
they create a new black hole
and go silent.
So in walks Ray Wise, who was
mentioned in the introduction,
sort of let's take us to the 1970s.
It's the 1970s people are
still arguing about whether
or not black holes are real.
They're still arguing about whether
or not gravitational
waves exist at all.
Ray Wise is a young professor at
MIT and he is asked to teach a class
on gravitational waves-- I'm sorry,
on Einstein's theory
of general relativity.
And he's just started a new gravity
program he's this young professor,
he's really, you know, wants
to make a good impression
and he knows nothing about
general relativity so he says yes.
So he teaches this class in
general relativity and he says,
he was bumbling, he was completely
bumbling he couldn't follow the
mathematics, he didn't
understand the theory,
it was incredibly difficult
and all he could make sense
of was this thing about
the gravitational waves
that he could just imagine, how
could I make that seem real?
If a gravitational wave like
a wave in the ocean pass
and something bobbed on the
wave you can measure it.
And he's an experimentalist
and so he's dreaming of ways
to measure this, the gravitational
wave, and that's the thing
that keeps the students
in the class.
He says they're not walking out,
you know, they're not walking
out because he's thinking about
real ways to understand it.
And he comes up with this idea
he called it a highku [phonetic].
It's for this little instrument and
here's the idea of the instrument,
you shine a laser, which
was new at the time,
down this L-shaped
instrument it gets split
at that beam splitter
there and shines
to the two mirrors,
let's watch it again.
Those little black circles at the
end are two mirrors that are hung
so delicately that if a
gravitational wave passes they'll
sort of bob on the wave.
And if they move because
of the gravitational wave,
the laser will keep
track of their movement
and it will record the
passing gravitational wave.
Now, you don't have to worry about
the details of the experiment,
you can think of this is like
the body of an electric guitar.
You know, if you pluck an
electric guitar string,
technically it doesn't
really make a sound.
You need the body of the electric
guitar to record the shape
of the string, you plug
that into an amplifier
and you play it like a sound.
In many ways, LIGO is
like a musical instrument.
It plays the wave back as sound.
So Ray starts to build this in
what's known as the plywood palace,
MIT's campus in the '70s.
It's a ramshackle structure that
was thrown up on the periphery
of the campus during
the war effort--
the World War II effort in an
attempt to get scientist invested
in technology important for the war.
It was supposed to be torn
down within five years,
it existed for 50 years.
And so the sheer crappiness of the
structure encouraged creativity.
Nine Nobel Prizes came
out of the plywood palace
and this may be the 10th.
Ray builds this tiny little
prototype it's a meter
and a half long, tiny
little prototype.
His colleagues are
telling him nobody cares
about what you're doing,
it's not important.
This will never succeed.
Black holes aren't real,
gravitational waves don't exist.
And they said even if they did if
the sun blew up and created a wave
in space-time, you could not
hear it with your machine.
We do better looking out
the window, and it was true.
You do better looking
out the window.
And Ray realized that he had
to build the real instrument.
It was 3000 times bigger than what
he was doing in the plywood palace,
with no financial support,
no community support,
and he thought he was doomed.
He told me once I started life
with one ambition I wanted
to make music easier to hear.
He was an immigrant from
Germany in, you know,
of 1947 he was a kid
building hyphys [phonetic].
And he would log speakers
that he found
in an old Paramount movie
theater that had been burnt out,
he would log them home to Manhattan
and he would build
these little circuits
and he would have all the immigrants
in the neighborhood come over
and listen to the philharmonic.
And this was his life's ambition.
And in some bazaar twist he
has his ambition as an adult
to become the one who
records, you know,
the symphony of the skies
in some sense, right?
And he sees this dream
of his passing
because he doesn't have funding
and he doesn't have support
and other people start to hear about
his idea, in Germany, in Japan,
in Scotland they start to build
these machines better than his,
bigger than his, more
likely to succeed.
And Ray says to me, you
know, I thought that was it
and then the next big
event is I met Kip.
And Kip Thorne is a famous
and iconic astrophysicist
and they team together, I'm going
to fast forward in the interest
of not keeping here all night but.
Fast forward to the year 200
they've accumulated a team
of almost a thousand people.
And they've secured hundreds
of millions of dollars
from the National Science
Foundation,
they fought bitter grievous
battles, people have literally
like climbing Mount
Everest there are
like bodies along the
way, it's gruesome.
But they get there, in the year
2000 they build these instruments.
This is the real LIGO machine
the one that's 3000 times bigger
than Ray's.
They are these L-shaped machines.
Along those tubes is a vacuum.
They are the two largest holes
in the earth's atmosphere
if you add up the LIGO machines.
There's less stuff in
those tubes than there are
in regions of interstellar space.
This is a little cartoon we're going
inside the tube and the laser shines
down the tube and hits a
mirror 4 kilometers away,
and bounces off the mirror,
keeps track of its location.
So if the mirror is
bobbing on the wave,
it will know that it
has bobbed on the wave.
In these, what we call
beer chambers,
are these elaborate components.
Now in the year 2000, all the
science runs they hear nothing.
The first generations of
machines were completely quiet.
And you can imagine the community
response to this initial generation.
But they weren't that
surprised on the LIGO team,
they always argued it would probably
be a second generation of machines.
The idea is that each machine
has to make a recording
or you would never believe it and
how it works something happens,
some cataclysmic event far away
and it washes over the earth
and rings the two machines.
This is what the machine
sounds like.
It sounds like noise.
They literally listen to the
instrument in the control room
through like conventional speakers.
This is, you know,
a process everyday.
My friend Rona [assumed
spelling] he's one
of the important experimentalist
on the team says he gets really
pissed off if the speakers aren't
on when he goes to the control room.
Then in August-- oh, this happened.
The Washington machine
is on the same site
as the plutonium separation
facilities that were used
in World War II for the first bombs,
the ones that were
actually used in Japan.
And that's because they
have to be on a remote site,
it's a government facility
there's no association
with the plutonium separation
facilities but it is kind
of ominous, you can see them
in the plums on the horizon.
And because they are nuclear
sites they have a lot of security
and I guess one of the
security guards is driving
around in the middle of the night
in this desert with a very--
like not completely
thoroughly flushed out knowledge
of the local geography and he
drives into one of the arms.
And I know this is not
a nice thing to say
but luckily he broke his own
arm and not the LIGO arm.
Had he broken the LIGO arm, not only
would the experiment have been over,
people told me, that's, it
we would have gone home.
Drawing the vacuum is so hard
that vacuum was drawn in 1998
and has not been brought
up to atmosphere since.
If that vacuum had been blown, as
one of my friends on the team says,
Mike Landry, he says, we
all would had gone home.
That's it.
It's over.
But not only that he would have
suffered much more damage presumably
than just breaking his arm it's like
opening a door in the space station,
right, only the vacuums on
the inside not the outside.
But it would have been very, very
dangerous for him to blow a big hole
in that vacuum very suddenly.
At one point they discussed
not even building
that cement encasement,
luckily they did.
So, at the other site, in Louisiana,
they were shut up my some hunters
who people think that was not an
accident that they were unhappy
about the scientific experiment
on their hunting grounds.
So one of the head of the Louisiana
site says we're so American
to the Europeans, you know, we've
had a car incident, we've been shot
up by guns, all we need is a
hamburger incident, you know?
So, in August 2015,
this is, you know,
15 years after the initial
machine was built, this is 50 years
after Ray started this experiment.
Ray works on that experiment
all the time.
I cannot tell you how
many times somebody said
to me we better ask Ray.
Ray walks those tunnels, he finds
wasps and vermin and chlorine
from the urine it was rotting
the tubes and he's the one
who discovers all the stuff, I mean,
he's really in the experiment
all the time in his 80s.
Ray says to be in August of 2015,
if we don't discover black
holes this thing is a failure.
It's a billion dollars into it,
and really, most of his life.
And the reason he said that is
that all the old timers they're
after pure space-time, pure
space-time coalescence.
That's what they want to discover,
nothing else will compare.
Meanwhile, all of the other
experimentalists including a lot
of the young people are
telling me, nothing until 2018,
don't expect anything until 2018.
Meanwhile the funding,
they're right on the edge
of the funding being not retracted
but it becoming a more
difficult argument to make
that this experiment should continue
to get funded at this level.
A lot of the astronomy community
is unhappy and against it,
doesn't think they'll ever succeed.
So, three weeks later
after this conversation,
it's September 13th a weekend
and Ray is working on the site
and he's looking for radio
interference and they decide
that they're not ready to start the
science runs yet and they're going
to keep testing the machine.
But he says, luckily my wife said
it's time for you to come home.
So he gets on a plane
and he goes to Maine.
It's late Sunday night, early
Monday morning and a lot of the team
at Louisiana and in Washington
are still doing these tests,
they're banging on the machine
they're driving trucks up
and down the access roads
breaking really hard to try
to knock the machine what
they call out of luck,
which means that in observing mode.
And eventually 4 in
the morning Louisiana,
2 in the morning Washington they
decide this is ridiculous we're
tired, we're going home.
They put down their
tools they go home.
Within an hour, they leave
the machine in observing mode,
within an hour on Monday
September 14th
after a 1.3 billion year journey
a gravitational wave comes
from the southern sky, it
rings the machine in Louisiana,
it's captured beautifully, 7
milliseconds later skimming
across the continent it rings
the machine in Washington State,
it's captured beautifully.
By the time Ray wakes up at 8:30
Monday morning looks at the log
and says, what the hell is going on?
It's already billions
of kilometers away.
And this is what they detected.
This is a computer simulation,
no telescope could record this.
They detected the collision
of two black holes one was
36 times the mass of the sun,
one was 29 times the
mass of the sun.
They heard the final
few orbits one-fifth
of a second this is
drastically slowed down so
that human beings can perceive it.
Each black hole is a
couple of hundred kilometers
across they were traveling
near the speed
of light in their final orbits.
They caught that let's see it
again because it's so beautiful.
They caught the last
200 milliseconds,
a fifth of a second before those
two black holes collided and merged
to make one black hole bout
60 times the mass of the sun.
That one black hole rang off all
the imperfections and went quiet.
And you can actually hear
this in the recording,
you can hear the black hole kind
of shedding away the
imperfections and going quiet.
It was not only the first
bear detection of black holes,
you could never see this in light it
was the loudest single event we've
ever detected since the big bang.
More power came out of that
collision than all the stars shining
in the observable universe
combined and
yet none of it came out as light.
All of it went into the ringing
of space-time ringing the drum.
And by the time it got to
the earth it was so quiet
that it moved the mirrors by
less than 1/10,000 the width
of a proton over 4 kilometers.
It was just an absolutely miniscule
faintest, thinnest wisp of a sound
that was finally recorded.
So, why don't we hear it
again and what you're going
to hear is actually that final chirp
that we've already
predicted in our simulations.
What's so stunning is
that the simulations
that people have been doing across
the world internationally are
so close to exactly what you hear.
So that is actually
what they recorded.
And by reconstructing from the
sound they deduced the size
and motion of the actual mallets.
And then just to close, since
this is a Book Festival,
I was going to actually just
read two very short paragraphs
from the end of the
book if you don't mind
and then I'd be happy
to take questions.
I think I can do this
with the podium, hold on.
I don't think it's a spoiler for me
to read from the end of the book.
You know what happens, they
discovered gravitational waves.
There will be press releases,
scientific papers will be published,
news articles will abound.
There will be documents,
reports, and careful records kept.
We'll continue to send a portrait
of our best selves into space,
a declaration that we were here
that we strove for understanding
that we often failed and
occasionally succeeded.
We heard black holes collide.
We'll point to where the sound
might have come from to the best
of our abilities, a swatch of
space from an earlier epic.
Somewhere in the southern
sky hauling away from us
with the expansion of the universe,
the big black hole will roll along
its own galaxy, dark and quiet
until something wonders pass
and interstellar dust
cloud or an errant star.
After a few billion years
the host galaxy might collide
with a neighbor tossing
the black hole
around maybe toward a
super massive black hole
and a growing galactic center.
Our star will die.
The Milky Way will
blend with Andromeda.
The record of this discovery
along with the wreckage
of our solar system will
fall into black holes
as well everything
else in the cosmos.
The expanding space
eventually silent
and all the black holes
will evaporate
into oblivion near the end of time.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And I think I'm taking questions but
I don't know what the clock says.
Oh, what's it?
Five minutes, sorry.
Please.
>> Do we know the speed of--
>> Janna Levin: Times
is relative by the way.
Yeah.
>> Do we know the speed
of gravitational wave?
>> Janna Levin: It's a
really important question.
In Einstein's original theory,
the speed is the same
as the speed of light.
We can tell that it took about
the speed of light to get
from the Louisiana machine
to the Washington machine
but we can't measure it that
accurately that we can say for sure
that it is indeed traveling
at the speed of light,
but the evidence suggest
that that's what's happening.
Yes. I think we're going
to trade back and forth.
>> You said that there was
like absolutely nothing
inside of the black hole.
Does that mean that absolute devoid
of atoms and everything in space?
>> Janna Levin: Yeah, so technically
the only way that we know how
to form a black hole at the
moment is through the death state
of a star, so a very heavy
star much bigger than our sun.
At the end of its life
when it runs out of fuel
and its interior collapses under its
own weight it no longer has the sort
of brightness and the
pressure to stay aloft
and it collapses under
its own weight.
And remarkably, Einstein did
not think that this would happen
but after studying
nuclear physics involved
in the bomb projects they realize
that there was known forces
it could resist collapse,
and the star will collapse
under its own weight.
Eventually, let's say it's 10 times
the mass of the sun, that object is
as it collapses becomes
like 60 kilometers across.
At that moment it creates
the shadow.
The region where the curvature of
space-time is so strong, sorry,
that not even light can escape.
But it doesn't stop falling.
The stuff keeps falling and it
falls all the way to the center.
So the stuff is not
there at that shadow.
What we call the event horizon
of the black hole is empty
by the time it's formed.
Where that material of the
star goes once it crushes
to the center, we don't know.
Again, it might blow out into a new
big bang inside the black whole,
a whole universe inside there or
it might get stored in some kind
of thing we don't understand
some kind of remnant.
We don't really know what
happens, but it's not there
at the event horizon anymore
that's for sure that we understand.
Yes.
>> Kind of a science
fiction question
like because I was always fascinated
like there was this theory
that like our conventional engines
they would never take us anywhere it
will take like hundreds of
years to go to the nearest star.
And there was this
lovely theory that like
with the black holes we can
actually maybe find some shortcuts
but like would anybody actually
survive going into like--
because I remember reading
those like endless fall
like people get stretched
into in like-- yeah.
>> Janna Levin: Yeah,
it's not a good story.
Not a good story in the
internal black hole.
It doesn't end well for
anybody on the inside there.
>> So there's no really potential?
>> Janna Levin: Well,
here's what we know.
We know that there are current space
craft, current technology had just,
just broken out of the sun's
influence voyager which was launched
in the '70s has just barely
escaped the influence of the sun
and that was from the '70.
It will be tens of thousands
of years before it makes
it to another star system.
Our nearest star at our current rate
of technology would take 35,000
years to send a space craft there.
There are these things
called nanocrafts
which are literally the size
of like a postage stamp.
And if we could accelerate those
too then they might get there
in decades.
But traveling at the speed of light
those star systems are only 4 years
away, OK, but we don't know how
to get anything near
the speed of light.
So the question is could we use
something like black holes is,
you know, that's not terribly
likely but it doesn't--
I mean, it doesn't mean, I mean,
warp drive is something we
can kind of try to make.
Like there are mathematical models.
A better thing to do would
be to warp space-time
so that you pull the star
closer, you walk across
and then you push it out again.
That would actually work the best.
I mean, literally you could get
there in a faction of a second
but we just-- you know,
we just don't know how
to harness energy sufficiently.
If we did we weren't be arguing
about oil and coal anymore,
you know, and fracking if we knew
how to harness energy like that.
I think do I have time
for one more question?
One more. Sorry for people in
the line but I can stay out here.
>> Sure. I was just
curious, in your mind,
what do you think the coolest
thing about this discovery is
like is it the fact
that Einstein's theory
of general relativity has
been further validated
or that this is evidence
of black holes or even
that this maybe a precursor to
even additional discoveries?
>> Janna Levin: I think it's not
that we've proven Einstein
right again.
I don't think any one is surprised
that gravitational waves are
real, or that they exist.
I think what's been
much more exciting is
that it's the first time we've
ever detected black holes truly
in a sense without looking
just at stuff around them.
Usually we look at what they're
doing, the stuff around them
and we say, oh there
much be a black hole
at the center there
creating all this havoc.
This is entirely different.
We are directly hearing the
collision of these black holes.
We've never seen two black holes
together because you can't see them.
And I think it points
to the possibility
that this is a completely
new dimension in terms
of understanding the universe
that this silent movie
that we've compiled is now going to
be accompanied by this sound track
and this sound track can get
ever more complex and rich
as we get more sophisticated
at listening.
And that's just, you know, it's
like pointing the telescope
at the sky for the first time.
I mean, that's what we hope, right?
We hope that we're going to discover
things we haven't even thought
of before because 95%
of the universe is dark
and the only way we're going
to detect it is by listening.
So thank you very much.
I'd be happy to sign
books or stay afterwards.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.